Your Microsoft research is full of nonsense
Speakers From Ara The Word Including Leading
Scientist Now Experts e Technology
Book Thurs and Leading Mixes and Makes
video of lecture freely
weak
alljobsforyou.com Turn Her Working With
With Mike and he's a star student at John's
Hawken University and Recently He is the One
Best Paper Award at Last Year Inter Speech
And then in the winning system f
aspire2
gung
i
i a must
this
I
ticket ticket
new and saw
Guri Maa
And Become Important in Current We Have Laf
There is not enough time to model on this data
So Before I Start With the Actual Talk I
What Would Like to Motivate the Research Goals
Behind this current line of work
So I basically agree on what is called
Distortion Stable Sequence Recognition
Problem So for Sequence Recognition
Part of this work we basically use models
Which are capable of tackling long term
and long span temporal dependencies in
Acoustic data and what would be in any model like
LSTA and A B LSTA and Any True Model
And for the distant stable part a v
Basically rely on training data to be very
Representative of the possible operating
Scenario in which the model is going to be
Used this essentially means that in most
Most of the cases we have an immense amount
Of training data and what we are faced with
The Challenge of Reduce the Training Time and
Also the decode time because if the models get
Really huge it's got to be a really big
Problem in terms of latency during
D
Code so in order to increase reduce the
Training Time There Are Several Different
Techniques So One of Them Is to Just Use a
Distributor Optimization Algorithm Butt
It turns out that even with distributor
Optimization If Each of Your Instances Can
Operate at a Really Fast Speed ​​You Do
Get a Significant Speed ​​Ups and That's
Part I'm Going to Consent On and Those
Models Which Are Capable of Fast Training
And for really low latency decoding our
Main Research Focus and I'll Try to Convince
You during the course of this talk that multi
Rate Neural Networks Are Really Good
Solution for these problems
So the outline of the talk is going to be like
This I will be initially discussing the
Problem Then I Discuss Few Of The Current
The approach we use to tackle this problem is
We Belong to Two Different Classes
feature based
Approach and Then I'll Show Actually
Introduce the Multi Rate Idea and I
Will show the application of this idea in both
Convolution Neural Networks and Recurrent
Architectures But Most of the Results
Right now we're just on the convo
Architecture Part Off
It's so what exactly is the issue in
Sequence Recognition So There Are A Variety
Of reasons you have a long span
Dependencies in input sequences like a
Sequence of speech vectors and the region
for that is
Inherent the inherent way in which speech is
Being generated which is by a
Articulatory system including physical
Constraints So They Cannot Be Rapid
Swiss Between Different Articulatory Status
So You Have the Tickle Effects Were Speech
Across a Wide Window is Getting Influence
By speech sounds from different foam
Across Several Different Time Steps and You
Also Have a Reasons to Like Riv Baresh Which
Are there any mental reasons why you have delayed?
Versus and Scaled Versus of the Speech
Signal Adding Up to the Actual Speech
Signal being recorded at the microphone
And finally they have various types of channels
Distortions Where the Effects Can Actually Happen
B Nonlinear and in Some Cases Adversarial
cases like
What Speech Encryption You Actually Have
Frequency Scrambling Techniques Var Ten
Distortions Can Be Quite the Savior So In
Order to Tackle All These Problems
we need
Two Design Models We Are Going to Remain
A stable to any of this
Distortion
So during the past two decades there have been
a variety of
Approachable and most of this approach can be
Classified A Feature Based
Model and Just Hope That Your Aesthetic Model Is
Going to Learn the Necessary Transforms
And the reason for that is that you increase the
Sequence of your feature vector you have
Increased Variance in the Input
Representation is inherent and in
Addition to that because of additional nonlinear
Temporal Warping That Happens in Speech This
Variance increases further so in order to
Learn Transforms Which Are Invariant To
True Highly Variant Input Representation U
Need a Lot of Data and Later on I'll Show
You that respect the amount of data
It's Always Going to Be a Problem So
Initially the approach towards this was to
Design Representation Functions Which Are
Going to Guarantee Some Form of Stability
To a Variety of Temporal Distortions and
This stability is usually defined as a
Life Continuity of the Feature
Transform and Sum of the Most Widel
used
Multiscale Feature Representations So In
Multiscale Feature Representations u
Basically there are analyzing features at several
Different Wrestles As Soon As You Have A Low
Resolution Feature Stream This Low
Resolution Feature Stream Is Going to Remain
Stable to local distortion in the input
Pattern But the Problem with This Is Really Low
Resolution Feature Streams Is That It
Also discards a lot of information
Which would be very important for
Classification So People Try to Solve This
Problems by Building Caustic Models
Operate on different feature streams and
Trying to Combine the Judgments from the
Acoustic Models Using a Variety of
techniques
So for example if you try these are too
The different plots are generated by
Different Multi Resolution Techniques
The first one is a simple Gabor filter based
Approach So and Here If You Look at the Plot
And Here So You Have Three Different Plots
Over Here and the First One Is the Really
Course Features and You Can Imagine That Any
Kinds of temporal shift in the acoustics
Events Over Here and Frequency Shift Is
Not Going to Influence That Representation
Impact That Represents a Great
Extent on the Other Hand You Have to Different
Counts of very fine resolution a fee in
Terms of Frequency and Here and Anywhere
Shift in the Acoustic Event Over Here Is
Going to immediately show up in this
Representation So If You Have An Acoustic
Model Who's Looking at All This
Representation Simal Nieves and a Bag of
Aesthetic Models Who Are Lucky At This
Representations You Can Hope to Both Be
Stable to distortions while preserving
Information Required Finer Resolution
Information Necessary So This Was One
Particular So Here We're Basically Taking The
Input Representation and Passing It Through a
Filter Bank Which Has Filters With
Different resolution this or this has
Also Been Done in a Different Way Were Instead
Using a filter bank you basically use a
Hiera Key Of Filters And What's Called The
Wavelet and you get a different style of
Representation but the Critical Idea
Here's basically decompose your
Representation into multiple resolutions
In addition to this there are also other cases
Of Techniques In Order To Capture This
Long Term Information in the Acoustics
Signal and One of the Really Important
Techniques Which Has Been Shown to Be Very
Influential for Adapta Is What We Call
A Permission in Variant Representations So
These Are Representations Why Not
Preserve any information about the actual
Sequence of data but they capture long
Term stationery information in the speech
Signal Like Se The Speaker Character The Ament
Characteristic and This Kind of
Information is giving as long
Term detail is very popular popular usage s
I vectors and main noise estimates
But there is an alternative approach in fear too
Tackle the Same Problem Long Term
Sequence Modeling and Which is the Model Based
Approach So How Atley D Model Based Approach
Deal with this problem so the model based
Approach As That You Just Have Sequence Of
Shirt is a tenuous representation which is
Something You See in an AACC Feature Vector
Sequence and Given That You Have This
Sequence of Short Term Representation U
Are we trying to model the long term temporal
Dynamics and We Already Know That We Can
Not Basically Slash a Long Window and Dump
It into the new so in order to tackle this
Problem Must of the Effective Models
Basicly Learn Temporally Local Transforms
So Every Transform Is Always Just Looking
At a fight chunk of feature sequence but the
How much truth is neural network able to process?
Information from a wider context and
There Are Two Strategies to Achieve This If
You are using a convolutional architecture
Can basically stack a do ash filtering so
You Can Stack a Series of Convolution Layers
And each time you go deeper into the network you
See a wider context but because of this
The wider context has gone through a layer of
Filtering its resolution has been reduced
To certain extent because of pulling and
Other Things So You Basically The Network As A
Whole I'm Looking at a Wider Context But
Each Transform Is Temporarily Low and Looking
At a lower resolution representation on the
Other Hand You Can Deal With This Problem In
The Recurrent Architectures Where You Are
Learning a Transform on the Input Its
Temporally Local But the Long Term Information
Is Being Captured in the State of the Vector
And this state can be detected using a task
Dependent Loss Function So It Will Preserve
The Necessary Details If We're Able to Train It
In the right way so I'll be talking now
We're interested in this two kind of
Architectures and in both these
Architecture's There Is This Edition Details
That's Not Only the Transforms Are Temporally
Local but also across time
Steps So Even If You Look in a Conversation
Architecture and Recurrent Architecture
The Same Transform Is Being Used Across Time
Steps and this shed statistic strength
Words That You're Learning More Than You Are
Learning Transforms Better Than Simple
DNA based
approach so because recurrent architectures are
So Popular in Order Popular Use in Tackling
This Problem Let's Just Initially Look At
The Recent Act Is So One If You're Just
Taking a Simple Hour with Anyone Who Feels You
It has several problems and one of us is
Basically limited memory so it is not able to
Memorize Tale of Tale in the Past and Itals
Has Problems of Vanishing End
Exploding gradients so in order to
Deal With This Issue Several Different Causes Of
Architectural variants
Propose and But Disappoint the Use of This
Architectural Variants Aren't This Very
Basic problem where the loss function is
During a That's That We Used to Train
The RNA cannot be computed parallelly
That's if you're computing the outputs
Off suddenly you all those outputs can not be
Computed Parallel and They Have to Be
Evaluated Sequential So In Order To
Overcome This Problem People Normally Use A
Batching of sequences so give basically a
Predict the Loss Function from Several
Different Success in Parallel but Disrupt Another
Use all these tricks the best
The Fastest Feed Forward Networks Are Always
Faster Than An Arran So This Is The Reason We
Decided to approach sequence modeling
Problem Initially Using Kaval Shall
Architectural processing output po just the
The hidden state factor is so simple
Network not the actual
Post So In Order To Tackle The Problem V
Actually Wanted to Explore Canal Shall
Architectures and We Wanted to Make Share
That the Canal Shall Architectures Were Not
Sufficient for sequence modeling before V
Shift to the Earn A Architectures
So As I Describe Before a Convolutional
Architectures Have a Variety of
Advantages Were the Main Advantage Over Here
Is That If You Have The Hidden Activations At
Different Time Steps at a Particular Layer
All These Activations Can Be Computed Parali
During Which Is Going to Be Give You a
GG Speed ​​Advantage During Training
But the problem is here if you want to
Increase the Context of the Network You
Here you both have to compute more
Hop in Your Unroll Convo and At the Same
Time You'd Have the Network as a Whole
To Process This Wider Context
Information So There Is Going To Be A
Linear Increase in the Number of Parameters
And also a linear increase in the compression
Cost as soon as you come to conversion
Architectures
So a very simple way to deal with this
The problem is basically use sub sampling so
Essentially We're Not Computing All
Outputs at Any Given Layer But Just Few
Of Them So You Can Think Or It Like This If
You have a filter with a fixed
Context and if you're not computing
Every Output at the Input
The context of the filter is basically the input.
Dimension of that particular transform
Reduce and essentially reduce the number of
Parameters and also because you are not
Computing Everything in the Convolution
Layer You Have a Speed ​​Advantage and This Is
Nothing new and people normally use this
Uniform Sub Sampling Strategy Ver De
Hop there filter by specified with and
It is popular use in all the scenes
Architectures But What We Want to Achieve
Is a sub sampling which is far more a
Savior Than What You Have From A Uniform
All Sampling Strategy So Late Have Been
Other Explorations of Non Uniform Sub
Sampling Strategy and These Var
Previously Done in Rachal Neural Networks
Where You Have a Two Independent Neural
Networks Cascaded But Both of Them Are
Train Independently So and Here You Have the
Advantage of Actually Decoding the Output
Of a lower level neural network looking at
The Individual Frames and Deciding Which
Of them are important and which of them
Frames Are Not So Important So One Of The
The Strategy People Used Was Basically Run A
First Pass D Code and the Output of the Lower
Level Neural Network and Just Select One
Frame Parr Every Context Dependent
state that you
Have But In Our Case The Problem Is That We
Have a normal DNA where every layer is
Decoded a Train Joint So You Can't
Assume a to have any understanding of
Importance at Half Time to Sleep in Order to Come
Up with the Non Uniform Sub Sampling
Strategy in This Particular Case V
Design Our Problem Like This So Given A
Designed Context That We Want to Model
Which is t a represented by t at over
There and the number of convolution layers that
I Want So the Number of Convolution Layers
Is the number of sequential operations that
Are Going to Happen in Network Which Will
Limit your speed a choose the filter
Context that is the context of the
Transform at each individual layer and the
Time steps at which this conversion
Convolutions Have to Be Performed and
Because we had no idea of ​​how this happened
To be done we came up with a criterion and
The Criteria Was We Wanted To Ensure The
Propagation of all the information from the
Input Sequence When We Are Trying
Compute One Single Output and We Wanted Two
Test Out That If We Design a Network
Satisfy This Criteria Are We Going
To take a performance hit in terms of
Convolution a neural network performs a
Performance So There Are Several Ways to Find
A path from the lower level sequence to the
Output Sequence By Assuring That We
Have Minimal Activations But We Also Have
This Other Constraint If You Remember That Hour
Convolution Layers Have Always Been
Temporally local and operate on a lower
Resolution Information So This Gives Us
Another Constraint That As We Go Deeper To The
Network We Are Going to Increase the
Contact off the network so it turns out
That if we just linearly increase the
Context of the network and basically
Just Elute the Outputs at the Edges of the
filter so in this particular diagram u
Can See That Previously If You Had a Normal
Convo network you will have computed every
Output at each layer and that would have
So many contentions which are represented
By every lines of all colors including
Black but if they are using the current sub
Sampling St
This is just fraud The colored lye is not black lye at all
And You Can See the Dick Reduction in Terms
off
cup
s i i
Even one so you get ent in the qualt meert
Similar Drp Ba Hai Mo Se
The window is at level so that the two sides are
Inputs and an object is only two inputs
give a f
two beats a f a i'm a i'll do that
TEX FI INPUT I F AND YOU GET
node d select type its value f the p
You flip a koi and ya say i use the f
i
Love essentially increases the compensation cost.
And or you have a two input filter and
Input Factors Increase the Couple Cost
Bic e double the number ramet b e e node the u
Select Lute or Use One Filter or the Other
Filter If you have a wider filter you can
Also so in this particular case one I want
To Compute the Output at One Particular
Frame in a Frame Dummies Training Scenario
You're Just Evaluating What You Know Ahead Of
Time That You Just Have to Compute These
Outputs And You'd Just Be Doing That But
If you had let's say a filter with five
Inputs Over Here That Would Essentially Mean
That I'd need a lot more contentions at
Each of the Levels That Is Below It If I
Are Making That Decision at a Really Low
Conversion layer it won't affect
A Law of Things But Because of the Dependency
Among the activations it could lead to a night
Like or partition the nodes into sets
Using the Two Inputs and Say Using Fi
Inputs Mala Ya And The Other Thing We Want
The answer is basically we need to have an
Understanding which architecture to
Use Both During Training and Decoding
So What You Say Might Be True That If I
Ramli Switch A
The activations that are used to update this
Filter I Might Actually Have a More Robe
transform but during decode time i
Need to Make a Decision on What to Use So
That Would Be An Additional Problem I Would Have
To solve I am not saying it is not possible
But
Gu o o the technical one or wai wai on the wa
They don't have to like it regularly
Am a if i had gun in fum both say it regal
luck the top
Down Rock at I Like A or So and Hear the
Activations Are Being Sectted Like This At
This level I need a filter vs so the basic
The Problem Here Is Dependency in Peach R
Emetic Left Emetic So I Always Need
Filters Which Have a Wider Left Contact
And this essentially means because of this
Asymmetry There Can Be Some Non Uni
Formally Place Samples So the Way We Draw
This chart is we select a particular
filter and we try to decide we basically
Decide What Activations Are Necessary To
Compute the Output of the Top Filter and
That's how this diagram works
At i thk the region wa imetric and view have
Overlap in the Orange Layer Where It's Not F
It's not a power of two expansion with that
Is the Reason Right a So We the Expansion Hour
Here's basically a power of three so more
Here at the initial level A and here I have
A filter which has a context of 3+
1 And Here I Have a Context of 6+ 1
And on top of that we have a context
Of 9 + 1 so depending on how exactly
I am
Prousing if a then you'd have perfect
banari tr
Ra So My Question So There Actually At
It's just I'm sharing one of my cups
Question it necessary for acre and it
Simply Tap I'd Something We Found That
It doesn't matter what structure you are using
As the age you are getting the propagation so and
Here It Just Turns Out That's Because of the
Inces I Chose I Chose Inces Of - Se And At
The Top Idea of ​​That I Could Have Chosen Mine
6 3 and this and billa a perfectly
uniform.com
where it is here where it is
Representing a bit of the left
Other Sub Sampling Methods
We Always Answer That the Center Frame Is
present and in order to reduce the
Parameters we do a use other tricks when
We are taking contact from so we
Would Just Take a Subset of Hidden Notes and
When Ever You Answer Certain Things You Like
Answer that there is a center frame and
If the left cortex is important then
Love's Answer The Late is More Representation Firm
The Left Contests You'd Get Better
Where was the performance and interview?
ad just dsh
P So the Big Advantage So are the Actual
Comp you would do in this session or net so by the
The Another Thing I Want to Make Clear Is And
Here's why we want to actually compare
Convolution Architectures and Recurrent
Architectures We're Not Talking About
Conversion along frequency but just along
Time So We Actually Have Fun
Transforms Which Are Operating on the
antaeus vector at a given instant but de
r j the affine transforms r being
shared across time
Steps So and Here You Can See That There Is
a
Drawstring Reduction in Terms of
Number of acts that are computed is it
Going to affect a performance oil
Discuss Later on and It Turns Out That
Using this particular sub sampling
Strategy We Are Able to Gain Up to Five
Times Speed ​​Up Compared to a Normal TD
Any Form of Sub Sampling Without Any
So In Afraid to Test Out the Basic Setup We
Started doing experiments on the
Switch Board LVC Task Just the 300 Aa
Subset version and I will briefly describe
The Setup Is Just Because I'm Using
This particular setup at several places in
This presentation so we basically use a 40
Dimensional MSCC Representation Which
Is essentially a filter bank but just with the
DCTT Transform and We Do That Because
We Want to Reduce the Bandwidth Usage When
We're Transferring Data Across Nuts and
In order to do what is term as instant
neus speaker
Dipped 100 Dimensional Aa Vector For Every
Time Frame and One of the Main Focuses
The technology we develop is that we want to
Answer that this technology is always ready
For online decoding so all the I vectors
That's being used over here are just meant
Using Data That Has Been Seen Till That
Position in the sequence and most of the
Systems That We Use Over Here Are Tray With
K cross amp when ever there equation
Discriminative Training Is Mention It
Specifically almost all the x all this
Experiments are basically done using the
Kadi Aa Tool Kit And We Use Them
Distributor Optimization Techniques
We Do Model Averaging Across
instance
And Or So the Edge Said One of the Goals Was
To Answer That We Always Had a Really Good
Online Setup and It Turns Out Even When
We're doing an online mean variance
Estimation There is a Certain Amount of
Latency Which Is Not Necessarily Due to the
Model But Just for the Mean Estimation So V
Just Wanted to Taste Out Weather There Was a
Way to Eliminate Any Kind of Mean Variance
Normalization and ensuring that the network
Learn It Ever is the Necessary
Normalization and It When We Estimate
Our IVectors V Estimator Non Mean
Variance Normalized Features So If There Is
Any mean re mean offset it is capture
Encoded in the Eye Vector and It Turns Out
That's by using our training recipe
The network is usually as effective as a
Network Which Don't Have Which Has Main
Variance
Normalization When We Use Knee Too
Introduce Literacy If You Want to At i
vector or as coming saying and here we answer that
The I vector is always estimated using
Data Scene Till That Particular Frame So If
You have a frame at 10 samples only the data
Up till that frame is being
Used So I Don't Claim That This Is Better
It's All Towards the Same Goal That We Want a
Really Fast Online System Which Doesn't Have
Any Latency Which Is Not Absolute Necessary
For the Model I'm Not Having the Sort of Game
Normalization That You Get From Mean
Traction So In Order to Tackle That
Problem We Have Other Solutions Yes That Is
A Really Good Question Because It Turns
Out That Most of the Training So If Any
Kind of Gain Difference Was There If It Was
Well Represented in the Training Data Hour
Model Would Be Roasted To That But Most Of The
Training Sunridge That We've Been Using Well
Curated Data Bases
perfect-scrollbar
The non-linear
W i d k i hai test a b der is one
additional fee
The There Is Nothing Explicitly Done to Tackle
this problem
लड़ी न लूठ बुट ओली एड ट्रे
don't sleep
no income
Gal
i nut
Or the beginning of what we have done
In heavy air flow from swans
Have Beslan Na This Is Yours
Beslan yes so what we see if you basically
Run It on the Single GPU You Usually Get
Better Performance Than Distributor
And doing an average but the performance hit
is not very
Drust a we've tasted it out but in the
Cases That I Did See I Would Basically Get
Something locked up and differential on P2
Switch Board 300 Aa Subset So We Don't
usually worried
Now I don't know what is so here.
Panam nonlinearities
In the feature hidden activation vector v
Select groups of 10 units which are
Basically Counts Sets of 10 Units and V
Take a we take some norm of it in this
Particular case here are taking the l2 norm of
These Activations So These Groups Do Not Assam
Any Kind of Location Special Locality and
Temporal Locality We Come Basically Select
Some set of 10 units in the hidden activation
Vector and Perform The Name and This Was
Basically Seen as a Generalization to the Max
nonlinearities
So these are the first set of results that
We Had So Let Me Guide You Through This Table
So the Initial Comparison That We Wanted To
Do Was Given the Same Amount of Context
That we normally use with DNA we
Going to See Any Kind of Advantage If We
Had tdn an architecture so in this
Particular Comparison I'm taking the
Actual context of 15 min 150 min
Seconds Which Is Being Modeled By A DNA
And Distributor Across Three Different
Convolution Layers So Have a Convolution Layer
Has a context of four and four
Say And It Turns Out That Even With This
Distribution There is an Appreciable Gain
But This Comparison Was Not Exactly Fair
Because as soon as you start using a
Convo Architecture There's a Certain Amount
Off Parameter Entries So We Conducted Otherwise
Experiment Where We Found That The DNA
Had the exact same number of parameters a
That as the TDN and even in this case there
There was a certain amount of increase in
Performance and after this we basically the
The main goal of the set of experiments was
To Actually See Weather We Can Model Anchor
Sequences using the dean and sell in
Order to test the TV started modeling
Wider and Wider Network Context and
It turns out that using the DNS server
Able to model context up to 230 ms
seconds in this particular a close stock a
Telephone Speech Case and One Letter on These Hours
Experiments V
Identification but the interaction is not
Clearly Understood So I'm Not
Bringing That Into the Comparison So Using
The TD We Were Actually Able to Model Cutex
Up to 230 milliseconds and once we see no
That This Contact Was Helpful We Actually
Wanted To Make Shar Weather The DN Could Also Do
This And It Turns Out As We Expected
That Any Time You Increase the Cuts of the Nun
Constraining the Amount of Ta That You Have
Is 300 aa in this case there is always going to
Be some kind of torment in the
performance
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
So could have like three and four values ​​or
And across the values ​​I don't see
Variance in Performing the One Thing That We
Select Is This Is This Are Not Hyper
Parameters We Have So Many Degrees Of
Freedom So We Initially Select the First
Layer Contact That We Want and This
Essentially Determine the Context of the Other
Two layers all that we want is to adjust the
The offsets and the adjustment of the offsets
Depends on the input contact of the
Network That You Want to Model So If You
Want to Say Model Just 10 Frames to the
Right and 350 Frames to the Past
Selection of this contact would differ and the
Another thing that we ne select is the number
Of Convo Layers That We Want and That Is
Usually a dishon made upon how many
Sequential Steps Are You Able to Tolerate
while you are
training just
Pop Lives The Best So It Sauce Lives The
Lew Number I Better Know What's The
best bay
A So If I Remember Right There Was Like A %
Difference on the switch board % or on the
Absolute on the switch board
Subset I Mean It Was Better But Not
significant
Better lines indicate some symmetry in the d and t.
tax brackets and square brackets
So so that's ready tomorrow and
slushy
ff
One after five is one o'clock twenty o'clock is one o'clock
Everything in the
Il
So the reason we want to do it is because we
Want to get the information at any time
Special Reasons to Make the Very First
filter
become dense
Ta everything is ty ok that's my
Questions So Lo Fa Everything That Is
Represented with the same color is computed
Fm a tight transform so it's it's
Represented with a color it is computed
From the Same Transform So All Along
Outputs R
K
Sorry so at this point of time we basically
Wanted to compare our TD model with the
State of the Art Results on the Switch
Board at that particular point of time end
In Order to Do This Comparison We Started
Adding a Lot of Bells and Wills to Ourselves
Baseline Model and One of the First Things
We Did What Was Basically Adding Pronunciation
Probabilities So Pronunciation
Probabilities Are Basically Once You Have The
Lexic witch has multiple pronunciation for
Every Word and You Have Your Training Data
After certain amount of training you
Basically Reline Your Training Data Using
This lexicon and what is the probability
off ch pronunciation
And the Next Thing We Did Was Basic
Simple Four Gram Re Scoring and After
That's What I Said Before
Sorry Prabash Buying Prabesh
Ya Ya So As A Said Before We Are Always
Interested in Online Technology So We Do
Does Not Do Any Kind of Speaker Adaptive
Training of our system and this
Essentially Means That We Usually Take a Hit
In Terms of Performance and in Order to
Compensator This We Basically Present The Same
Audio Data to Our System as a While Simulator
Synthetic speakers sleep normally in
In order to simulate the synthetic speakers a
People Have Been Doing Vocal Tracks Late
Perturbation and tempo perturbation but it
Turns out that both of this can be done
Using a Simple Signal Processing Operation
Which is basically compressing and
Expanding Your Signal Whenever You Do
Compression You're Putting Both the Tempo and
Because this compression modify your
frequency
Quotes There is also a disturbance in the
AACC
Why Fun We're Hacking the Soup and This
One of the biggest advantages of this speed
Perturbation Technique That It's Aign Off
Your Feature Representation That You're Using
And It Turns Out That's a Very
Critical Decision for Many People Who Want to
Use the Techniques in Different Systems
Following up next question so you're saying that
You basically sometime present your sapling a
8 Sometime at 7 and Half So You Can Think
off it so we sample it at different rates but
We Always Assum That The Sampling Rate Is 8
To So That Essentially Means That You Are
Air That Gives You The Stretching Room
compressing effect
I was able to use the synthetic data or apps.
Combine or OK so the volume disturbance is
The Thing That Actually Helps Us Tackle The
Mean gain normalization issue so we basically
Train Hour System Using Several Different
Perturbations of the Volume and It Sold
Volume of the antenna
signal the
Gail Understands So Now You Just Said You Always
assam e
So so basically if you have signal at x of p
You Now Want a Signal at x of Alpha t Ver
alpha is even number and in order to 7.5
This is just a ripple effect
mr ny ni
Not So Soon As You Ripple It At 7.5 And
Pretend That It's 8 Coloh You Have The
compression effect
ok separately common
A late paper last inter speech with that
And It Turns Out That Across Several
Different Data Sizes We Tested Data Size
Up till 1800 the usual guesses are 6 to 7
But Relative When We Do Speed
Perturbation and volume same volume
Perturbation in Most of the Tasks that We Have
Over Here Both Our Training Data and Tests
Data Are Very Well Curated So You Don't See
A Lot of Gain But There Are Other Tasks That I
Present Letter on Where That Essentially Led
To almost a 15 per relative gain because in
In that case the gain differences in the test data
Var several hundreds of
db fur
sold
Ya Sotus The Ya So The Basic Idea Here Is
Try to Do as Much as You Can While You Are
Training to Answer That's Decoding Setup
Is As Online As Possible I Have A Question
this look
online ha level a a sa
TR Challenge V
The No So Aa I Have Some Riddles Not The Challenge
And When We Even Started With The Challenge If
Veer Constraining Also to Be Online Veer
Relate degradation just on basically 10
Because we are imposing the online constraints
Respect When We Are Estate
When We're Not Doing Any Kind Of
normalization of hour
Data So Because of the Challenge Because of the
Benchmarks We Had to Relax the Challenge But the
The Online Thing Is Just Like a Broader Goal
That We Want to Achieve So Any Technology
That We're Using So We Don't Want To
Invest a Lot of Effort in Doing Speaker
Active Training Where We Require Three More
Four Passes on the
data
So Then We Added What We Call Silence
Probabilities So Usually When We Have The
Silence Arranging Between the Probability of
Silence between two words is an assumption
To be uniform in a normal lexicon but
And Here We Wanted to Bring a Sure
About an idea in the context of
Silence affecting the duration of the
Probability of the Silence and It Turns
Out That Do The Guess Because Of This Silence
Probability Estimates Are Not Very High
In this particular case when we go to rob
Speech Recognition Task We Get A
significant guess because of that
particular thing and
In So If You Have a The Probability of a
Silence Ring After Any Word Normally It's
Seen To Be It's Assumed To Be Uniform But
Oh Here We're Worrying the Probability of This
Silence Depending on the Previous and the
Next Word Word So It Like Mal Sort Off
how you tran
So basically this was work done by one of my
Colleagues Gogo Chan So and Here If We Actually
R introduce all this additional aux in
Order Two Moodle Models All This Different Silence
The Probabilities You'll Have a [ __ ] Increase
In the number of ox depending on the
Vocabulary so basically partition this
Probability Into Different Parts Were
You Try to See What the Impact Is Just
Because of the previous word and multiply
It with the impact of the next word and
It's basically model as an independent
Probability and There Are Several Tricks
Over there in order to insure that its
Actually Easy To
Implement And On Top Of That We Did
Sequence Training and Further What We Did
There is one minor adjustment over here this
Is Not A This Is Sequence Training But On
The Top of That We Do Something Call Prior
Adjustment So This Was Something Which Was
Founded by one of my colleagues called Vimal
Manohar when he was doing semi supervised
Training with Neural Networks only
Identification When We Want to Estimate
The likes instead of computing the
Prior based on the alignments if you use
The Prior Who Is Aimed from the Mean
Posterior of the network if you use that
As the former it gives a lot of gains and
And here you can see that this gain is
Consistent and it turns out that after
Finding We Started Using This Trick
Across a Variety of LVC AR Tasks and
We are consistent across all this we made
The verse came from the very beginning and
Switch Off Because It Makes Butter
r
Ra
stop so at the point of
Time the Papers with the Best Results
Switch Board 300 Set and We Do Seat We Are
Definitely Able to Perform Better Than The
Unfolded R Implementation by Jan But This
Is Definitely Not a Fair Comparison or in a
Proper Comparison Because the Sets Differ in a
Variety of Veg Letter O A A G A Cup B D T
And the l sh a l off
Seth Bamla
ब व सिलम य गेटला
300 tons when
c b
No system has speaker attribution and out
Offline Estimation on One Single Eye Vector
At or sorry i t x i already mention the
They are used in the system maintenance and so on.
Incremental The Online ICTs Are Used In
Avery came down
print so the bottom la
Have this one
No so come all show you results with r
Letter So I Vectras Yuli Gave Us Across
Ta Around 7 But Relative But If We Go To
Far feed recognition task like ami and the
Another Task That I Present Here We Get
bigger gas
E in whenever we do or even in the
Incremental Fashion We See Guess But If We Turn
Off the Incremental Thing and Start Doing
Offline Estimation The Guess Slight Gate
slightly
Better So Once We Did See What We Were Getting
Improvements because of the TDA and
Models We Start Testing Them Out On
LCS and Tasks of Different Data Sizes
And We Found That Across All This Task
Which has data range from 3 to 1800
Reduction on Hours We Do Get 5 to 7
Relative Reduction in Word Error Rates There Was
Just Some Discrepancy in a Resource
Management Tasks But We Don't Do a Lot of
Tuning on that so these guys are consistent
And because of this we started using the
TDA as the standard DNA recipe in
Kaldi Tool Kit
So Now the Comparison Between the TDN A and
RNA So After That Paper Was Published We
Actually Wanted to Compare a Locally What
Were the Best RNA Numbers That We Could Get
And It Turns Out That Disappoints the Clims
Of Having the Best TDN Dean Being Able
To Tackle Long Term Sequence Dependencies
They are still performing versus nl
ATM So Here Have Numbers on a Switch
The board task is the same as the telephone speech task.
And the Aami Single Distant Microphone
Task End In Both These Cases You Can See That
There is a degradation because of switching
From R A to a Simple Canal
Architecture
And So That's One of the Efforts We Are
Doing Right Now So and Here You Can See That
The Best Numbers That We Have Over Here Are
Because of a bi directional LSTA end
This Brings Inherently a Lot of
Latency into the model even if you do chuck base
Training There's a Lot of Computation Overhead
Because You Would Have to Compute the Right St
Off the Model So Right Now We're Looking At
Efforts We Are Making I am Making An
Effort Where the Right Contact Is Being Model
Using the Left Context is Being Model
With an LTA and the Right Side Context
Is being model with atd aa and i am
Trim
to ok
So So the Right Side Contest Is Being a Model
We So the Essential Idea Is If You Want 20
Frames of Context to the Right Raad Dan
Directly Dumping It Into the Previous
Model So Write Now The Trick People Use in Fear
To model right context with LSTA is
basically predict label with
Delay so you should go update your status of
LSTM for five more time steps before
You
Predict Output So Right Now We Are
Try to Combine These Two Things and Achieve
The Performance of the LSTM
The work that has results and I come back from the
Right Cutex Using Neck
Banke P
Detect but Similar Tube Training
under soot yr yuli
Use most activation or compute for write
Cut Also Be Used So It's Particular
You have to read this propagation step and
Every Time You Do
SHIFT LEFT HAND SIDE COTEX E COMPLETELY
I have done a normal lesson for you.
are side
I ok ok so if you want to do it for
New Chuck You Would Do
The
OK Alji l son so y able t in yo middle y
basley rus a lat
the e
Fum
कोल बेसली है डी स्सोय क इजेन
Also the LTA Actually Do That So in the
LTA We Don't Just Do a Rans to Spie Off
-1s the lowest
lm3 The LTA On Top Of That Has A Step
Off-6 and the one on top of that is a
Step Off-9 So If You Unfold This Model You
Can See That We're Not Taking the States
From All the Lower Layer
Outputs It Actually Improves the
Performance So This Is The L We Hat
this philosophy
Minor It's Not Subtly Different But the Main Reason
You should do that if you want to get speed gun or
Doing Sense Level Objective Training Lock
c w t code d u y e m e n t a so d o r
Cuts Reasons Are Locked Later Results Done After The
paper sleep
Quell so y said on ba doing subling
Trick Don't Lose With Confirm S
she came here
Peaches Tough the End I Have Xmen
Duff 12.1 No. B.E.E.D.
All action taken in the late budget SLPR
The Work I Do What to Make the Really St So
no
this time
Here's So With The Dean There's This Extra
Hyper Parameters Which We Have to Adjust
What is the amount of left context
That We Need and This is Usually Done Empire
The bud and it as I discuss it before there are
Lot of interactions in the model when we
Switch the Nonlinearities
Out That We Could Actually Model Wider
Context Rad Dan Just Going Tall 230
Milli Seconds I Was Able To Go To 300 Milli
seconds so this additional hyper parameter
Tuning Brings in a Lot of
issues so
Azumin Have A Really Because We Still Had A
Really Fast TD So in This Particular Case
I would like to make a comparison of speed
Between the TDN and the LSTM So Here
The TDN A is Three Times as Fast
LSTM So Because We Had This Really
Fast Model Which is Still Able to Tackle a
Context of Greater
length
What about ACA that's three
Times Fast for Apple has Three Times
in lace
patas so
Here all these models have similar number of
Parameters so there is not much difference in
Terms of the Number of Actual Multiply
That's Being Done We're Just Doing Them
Paley sequential that the major difference so
tight
ham a
fast a
Last time I made some money and
That'll lead to some improvement in oil
Definitely taste the
Out So Given That We Had All This Sample TD
Model Ch wa operating very fast and at the
Same Time Doing a Lot
Off Wa Able To Train No Lot Of Data V V
Wanted to taste this out in the f-fee
Recognition Tasks We Know to Have a Lot of
Sequential Dependencies in the Data
And what exactly they do is the fa feel
recognition task
A So Bad in Terms of Dependency It's
Usually because of the late riv baresh so late
Riv Baresh Are Reflections of the Actual
Signal Watch Happens After 100 Milli Seconds
And usually the late rebrushes are non stationary
So Noise Rubs Techniques V Rob Techniques
Which Assumes a Lot About the Stationarity
And they are not the same sources
Moving Are Very Difficult to Apply When
We Have a Ribbed Signals and the Others
The problem is late ratio with late v baresh is
They are the actual speech signal which is
Being Added to the Speech Signal So It's You
Can assume that they are very related with
Speech But in Most of the Normal Techniques
People Assume That Those Are Not Related
Because there is sufficiently long delay
Between the Actual Signal and the Reflection
But It's Still Not So If We Want To
Tackle Late Night Situations You Can See Immediately
That's Any Model Who Has the Ability to Model
Wider contact may be able to learn
Invariant and Stable Representations When
we have
This is why we wanted to test out
The TD AS A In The PA Field Recognition
The task and it we choose we decided to achieve
Participate in a challenge which is called the
Aspire Challenge and One of the Qualities of
This challenge was very beneficial to us and
That was there was a well defined mismatch
Between the training data and the development data
Also the evil data so the training data was
Just Clean Telephone Speech 1800 Ars Off
Fischer data the only information given to dave
As was that the test sets are going to be
With Reverb There Was No Kind of Meta
The data that was supplied
For us to test out our models was a
Being was expected to be sufficient
Different from the average data so in the average data
Later or Greater Number of Rooms Different
Microphones Different Types Different Speech
Scars and Speaker Microphone Relative
Positions are very different so this was a
Really Good Task to Test Out a Model Watch
CAN MODELS WHICH CAN TRAIN ON A LOT OF
Data So These Are the Sources of Variables and
These Are the Typical Room Confine If You Are
Interested I can discuss further so let me
Play out some samples from this particular
Tasks you should do as a blogger
Started like 11 years old 10
10 Years Old He's a Video Blogger and Tired of It
kald
Footies and He
Just so's the typical example that's mine
Who Who Conducted the Challenge Wants Us to Play
So this is the lowest error rate that we had
Speaker error rate with the model is 26
And this is what it sounds
Like
or its
Interesting I Actually Just Recently
Found Out Like Some of Two Wives Are Lonely
Real Hair B Eyed In
No So You Can See That The Data Is Very Easy
For Humans But Very
Def Ya Ya So It's Easy for Humans and We
Had 26 Error Rate With Our AR System Now
Third One It's Still Very Easy for Humans
But We Started Getting Higher
hi haas
gun m g mango
Dev Ya Ya We Tucked Before
Ackley or
Hello so this was a really hard sentence
For Us Because We Started Getting 41
Rate Do We Were Able to So I Only That May Be
It was buzzed by the keyboard and started
Verifying the Actual Hypothesis and That
Was not the
Region h that's in these directions
nut
ak
or because of late
Low And This Was Much Harder
ff ha
this
aa yik topic so
Basic problem aa der eif apla g la
Technicals Daily SD Signal More Sell Late
Close Source Actual Microphone
Moving and leaving the speaker in the
background sleep
Simply So The Second Last
One Mango Plays the Second
Last
yachts
Know If You Have a Really Good Headphone and Listen
To do it very carefully
But so it comes out we had to amplify the
Signal Several Times Before We
Actually Know It Was 60 Error Rate Er I
notan
Or So This Was One of the Things That Was Very
Tough For Us A Sr Never Generated Any
output for
This sorry so this is this
Size S This is the actual data This is data
These are samples from the data that give
Gave As This Is Ri
ta ta ya so
abuse trascribe
This is really good gay control you can
Actually Start Lining
To so how much i this in training set so the
The training set is only known because of this.
Training is just telephone so we have to
D a l t o simulation
The smoke makes all sense p has got naz video
make life
every
fun the so this the f
This Nam Peep can transcribe with this is also
J telling them what they should put
Deva So If You Think That's Worse You Should
Probably Lynn
To So L That Id Make Out Was That There Was
A female pen and paper to transcribe
You Know 80 Errors Sos V
Or So Do's The Kind Of Couple That We Are
Dealing With When We're Starting With
chai speech
One So For The One Before That If Ya Had Game
control last
I Don't Know You're Actually Able to Make More
day any off
As so we have about 20 minutes ok
Yes So Are And Here You Can See That There Is A
Lot of mismatch between the training and the
Test Data So We're Our Only Solution to This
Was basically collect as many room impulses
Responses That We Could Find Open on the
Internet and Try to Data Our Data
Using All These Impulse Responses and If
late any corresponding
Impulse Responses We Also Did That Too
Our Data So Doing This We Basically
Created and in order to tackle the late
Baresh We R We Just That Using Our Dean A Word
solve the
Problem so these are the first set of
The results are on in the top section of the
Table of Contents Comparison between Normal DNA
And Tdn But Here We're Not Doing Any
Kind of
simulation distortion simulation end
Training Data and You Can See That's the Error Rate
Is 47 And Just By Adding All This Different
On the grounds of reverberation we get a 37
Relative Gain and Which is Quite
Drawstring
And sorry so we basically increase the amount
of training data three times by doing
Different Choosing Different Pairs of Rooms
Impulse Response and Actual Speech Wave
file
So what was your relative improvement from
Dean A on Clean Data
Buffer It Was 57 7 True
Great G In The Press Of Or We Can Because Of
This two columns so one we do match the
Training Ta and When We Do Different
Kind of Disto the Performance of the
DN is a 33.1 and that of the Dean that the
Bust That We Could Get It
30.8 So If I'm Ready Even in the Clean Speech
Go Atto gives you 5 to 7 reasons
Say I'm Just Making the Claim That There Is An
Improvement and there is a sustained
Improvement I'm Not Saying That In This
Particular case the model is going to be far
Better But Less You Have
The t is specifically suitable for address
The Lug Range Pendency But Now I Meet You
So the problem is that long range
Pendency is helpful in all AR scenarios
They Are Just More Predominant in Far Feed
Recognition So and Also There is Another Change
Over Here That's the Amount of Training Data
Increased from 300 to almost 5500 rupees
So using this larger amount of training
Data the DNA could have sold some
Issue you can argue less benefit or more or
You Don't Know At That Point of Time
We Didn't Have a Local Implementation and
It Would Definitely Have Taken a Lot Longer Too
Train using the LTA and training time
Was the Most Critical Thing Here Because
Most of the Guess We Were Getting Because
Off Simulate the Data So the Most Significant
Gain and Here's the Relative Gain Which at 37
Is just seeing more amount of data now
a u d
A Not Yet So This or the Maximum So
After doing this experiment most of the
People in my lab started teasing me because
I'm taking the GPU so you don't g
we have 50p b i was using l of them for
A Period of Two Weeks and Everyone Ted So
I couldn't do anything any more
Experiments After This Aay Is Only Ex
Your Error Is 3 The I Worth It
Yanni jeep du use in one training run so
In this training run we use 32 in one run so
You Do Model Averaging Over 32 O We Had To
Do That Because We Needed The End Even With
That We It Took Us Three Days to Train
So We Don't Make I Don't Make Comparisons
Almost Every Task It Was Very
The specific task is modifying how the
Number of Jobs Affected by the Results and It
wa lovage in the
Range So One Another Interesting Thangi Sa Wan Vi
Using in feel recognition basically anchor and
Langar Context Help and Where We Go
To Very Specific Task Lock Amy We Saw
That We Were Even Able to Model Context Up
Till 500m seconds using
TDS So let's take a look over here at
Various Things That We Did So This Was Ours
The system we submitted to the challenge and
After the Challenge We Started Adding Each other
Things Like We Are and Elms and We Were
Still Able to Improve on the Results But
This is the result that we were comparing with
The Other Sites So in All the Sites You Can See
That the results on the dew test are similar
But When We Look at the Result the Evil Set
What is the actual comparison being done you
Can See That There's a Drawstring
That's Just Because of the Very A Greater
Variance in terms of the average test set
That we had so this shows us that mismatch of
A data is still a problem
Despin on what we could do to ourselves
Training Data There Was Still a Lot of
Unseen Data That We Couldn't Deal With Even
With the Dave Set Over Here We Were Getting Good
Error Rates But We Didn't Even Select The
Room Impulse Response Based on the Dave Set
Data We Didn't Use Any Meta Data
Information When We Were Doing Our Room
Impulse Response Selection So I Will Just
Briefly discusses some of the ongoing work so
Let's come back to the same slide which is a
Comparison between LSTM and DNA
Answer Your Questions So When We Start
When We Have TD AA and When We Are
Going to use them with sequence level
Objective Functions Where We Are Going To
Compute Several Outputs Simal Real You Can
See That We're Actually Going to Use Several
Intermediate Compute Several Intermediate
Activations Do Nut for the Current Output U
Would There Anyway Be Computing for Them?
Next Output So It's Not Actually
Necessary to Increase the Sub Sampling Rate at
True an exponentially decreasing scale so and
Here you can see that in order to compute the
The first gray output you are computing is
Time Sp Over Here And In Order To
Compute the Orange One We're Anyway Going To
Shift Right So If We're Going to Do This
The Cost of Computing the Intermediate
Outputs can be basically distributed
Over the Ant Chunk on What We're Doing
Sequence Training How Ever If We Actually
Want to Use All These Outputs We Still
Have the Linear Increase in the Number of
Parameters that still remain a problem
So in order to solve this problem we
Decided to Explore Pooling Options So
Basically If We Wanted If We Had a Net
Filter at the Next Layer Which Was Just
Using Two Outputs and We Want to Use All
The Data We Use Different Terms of Pulling
At the lower level in order to reduce the
Sampling So We Tasted Three Different
Causes of Samp Pulling Which is Basically
Using Wadi Conversion Which is Here Fixed
To be a smoothing filter and a filter
What is learned but what is common across all
Feature Incest So We Basically Have a One
Dimension Conversion Filter What is
Shifted across a feature essentially and basically
Using a different filter for each feature
Index So These Are The So These Are The Results
With the original gross entry B objective
There Was a Difference Between All Samples Dean A
And the LATA and this is the same sub sample
DN Which Has This Exposily
Decreasing Sampling Rate as We Go Deeper But
If We Increase the Sampling Rate and Answer
That the sub sampling rate is the same at all
Levels So If We Just Fix It to Be Three
We Do See a Slight Gain and When We Remove
The sub sampling completely and using all the
Frames But Decrease The Parameters Using
Pooling and when we use it for dimension
Filters We Do Cific G So To Answer Your
Question there is a problem because doing everything
Sampling But If We Wanted To Do The Same
Thing in normal frame based frame Ramaz
Training has been increasing in
Training time is almost 10 times
depending on
how
ल ल ग 3 ले 3 तिव फुम सक्स या सो ए ए ए
Said these are very preliminary results which are
Just From Last Week And After So Done Did
Some Debugging and He Did Find Out That There
There are very specific issues in using the
Sequence Level Objective with the LSTM
And Right Now We're Trying to Rectify
That's What We Do Hope That the LSTM Will Give
As Slightly More Benefits But the Main Thing
That I Wanted to Highlight Over Here Is
That's Removing the Sub Sampling Actually
Helps and There's a Slight Gain Between
The Original TDN And That We Had And A
TDA A Who Is Making Use Of
Information at all the inputs and this
Comes to us without any additional cost because we
Are Using a Sequence Level Objective and
We Can Share the Compassion Across the Entire
Why So Aiming That We Do Finally
Sorry
time all
Spl or e in at deco time you love have
Chunks Right So It's Always a Non Sub Sample
Model So Even Before You Time We Don't Gain
A lot because of the TD because you always have
Chax
s / o
Azumanga Menace of the LSTM There Wood
There will still be a gap in performance between the
TDN and RNA Model So We Started
Looking at Ways of Actually Taking an Hour
A Model and Trite Improve It
Performance up to the level of a normal
LSTM while assuming that it had all the
Multi Rate Nice Properties That We Want
Which is really low training time and it
Turns Out That One Really Already Exists
What is basically called the clockwork arn
In the clockwork ain't let me brief
Describe What It Does So Rather Than Just
Having a Simple Recurrent Unit
set of recurrent units u partition the
Recurrent Units Into Individual Groups
Where Each Group Is Running at a Different
Clock Rate So Sum of the Recurrent Units R
Just Being Updated Once Every Time
Steps While Some Are Being Updated Once
Every four and once every at time steps and
One Other Thing Onev Dar Palti About This
Architecture Is That There Are Always
Connections only from the slowest units
Slow Units to the Faster Units So Here
IE have a set of units which are operating
At r/4heartandthisjusthasconnections
To r/2 and r there is no connection
From the Faster Units to the Slower
Units So What Does This Actually Mean So
This is a typical recurrent complaint that you have
And here each block corresponds to one
Partition of the matrix and each color
Corresponds to a particular sampling rate
So if you have a normal recurrent equation you
Would Have a Full Matrix Over Here End
Instead of the full matrix you are
Parting the And Here White Means There Are No
Parameters There Are No Parameters Because
There Are Just Connections from the Faster
Units to the Lower Units So If You
You're Computing the Fastest Rate Output
You're Using All the Partitions Too Slow
Rate Outputs But If You're Computing A
Slow Rate Output You Don't Want to Use
Any Parameters So This Essentially Reduces
The Number of Parameters is Half Which is a
Good gains and on top of that only this
Particular block is computed every time
Step This particular column is computed
Every Two Time Steps and So On So There
Is really great reduction in the amount of
Competition That Is Going On And Also In
The Number of Parameters But These Are Not the
Main Things That Make This Model Very
Attractive the biggest gain because of this
The Model Is That It Improves The Memory Of The
The Network and That Happens Because the Model Is
Basically looking at input data at different
Temporal Scales and It's Many Different
Paths into the past each with different delays
So this is essentially a show that they know at
All shows that this model is very comfortable and
In some tasks I am able to match and exceed the
Performance of LT so because it was so
Attractive Problem A Only Speech
Problem given at word level
Classification So We Tested Our Performance
Of this model no speech task and it was very
bad it wa
[ __ ] Prum Ridge So On This Acoustic Modeling
Task The Performance Was Very Bad It Was
Far Worse Than the Normal DNA and So We
Started making modifications so one of the
First Things We Did Was There Was All
Sampling Happenings in the Network So What
Is Something Every Signal Processing
Engineer Wood Do Have An Anti Alia Sing
Filter to ensure that there is a smoothing
Of information and an sure that
Information from all the time steps is
Used in the Filter the Second Thing We Did
Was a we removed the hyperbolic activations
That Were Being Used in the Clock Conan and
Based on the Experiments by Kwok Lee
Last Summer We Started Using
Rectified Linear Units and the Diagonal
Inish Essay That Suggested So Age Soon
We Started Using Anti Alia Sing
Filters We Saw a Good Gain When We Use
Rectify Linear Units That Was the Measure
Gain and the Diagonal Initial Inclusion
Gives us a slightly larger gain but which
Is Not Very Consistent And In Order To
Reduce the Output Dimension We Just
Started Using the Fastest Units
Because of these aesthetic models you are waiting for the
Output At Every Time Sp We Thought That Only
The Fastest Outputs Would Be Sufficient So
All This Gave Us Really Good Guess And Finally
We were able to substantially improve and the
Original Clock Kanan But The Results Were
Still Just As Good As Dean I'm Not
Presenting the Results Right Now Because of the
Experimentation is not extensive and I
Don't Think I Can Make Strong Claims
So Right Now We're Still Looking at Ways Too
Improve the Performance of the Clockwork Ars
And one of that would be to just simply use the
Clockwork Aarn Idea In Any L Model That
is already performing very well which is
Using it as you control different gates in
An LSTM So the Only Thing Here Is
That's When Ever You Have a Recent Matrix
You Can Partition the Recent Matrix and
There are a lot of models where you have
recent
matrices e e e e e because actually the re is
Fix you have a fu and ha and ctor and
Something So I Think the Power of Esteem Is
Young Gut So I Art to Control the Flow
Ofen I Thi This Kind Definition Kind
Probably So But You Can See That It's Not
Essential to Love's Have a Fixed Set Off
Rates You Could Actually Choose to Elute This
Parties At Any Rate That You
What do people do with the history?
fee back comes f a c a v max p so s
Max Pulling Over History Should Give You
Li b ly like align thi soots wt jf wa
Suggesting Before the Meeting Were You
Basically Wanted Different Histories to Be
Contributing to the State One You Are
Making the Current Prediction But in Your Case
You're Adding the Additional Layer That's Wrong
Combining problems with this history
Want to Do Some Kind of Pulling Operation
Never Ever Tried I
Rest Forward or Definitely
Why so let me try to surprise what I
Didn't wait now
Ah so basically we should do that multi rate
Architectures Provide Us Good Guess So The
Models Buy Them Sales Are Not Powerful
Compared to their non sampled variants
But the major advantage that you get because of
Multi Rate Architectures Is The Speed
Advantages and what speed guns can be
Trivially Converted to Performance Guess
By using more training data and in many
Cases Like the Aspire Challenge Scenario That
I Shad the Most Critical Thing Was Seeing Age
As much training data as you could and this
Kind of Architecture These Architectures Give
As Really Good a Way to Do That and Another
Advantage Which I Don't Talk About A Lot In The
Multi Rate Architectures Are That They Operate
On Multiscale Representations So In This
The particular architecture of the input vector that
is being at this particular clock and immediately is
Being Smoothed Out So Soon As You S
Doing Smoothing If You Remember the Very
First Slides I Should You Actually Get
These Multiscale Properties and the Input
Over Representation Here Is Going to Have
This Rice Really Nice Distortion
Stability Guarantees and Because I Can Do
This smoothing at various levels is desired a
I Don't Only Have Really Fast
Architectures but also architectures
Which Can Be Really Rob If I'm Able To
Properly Get the Training Done So This Is One
Other Reasons That Multi-Rate Architectures Are
Very attractive even in the TDN end
Architecture as we go deeper into the
Network It Was Actually Seeing Lower End
Lower Resolution Information So the Ar
Advantage of multi rate architectures is
That They Actually Have Access to Multiscale
Representation So if you want more details
About the things that were discussed in this
Particular talk you could go through our
Interspeech Papers Let Me Briefly Describe
The Future Work So As Said Before The
The problem that interests me is the distortion
Stable sequence recognition problem
You Have Long Term Sequence Dependency
And Sequential Distortion in Data This
Challenges are assisted in all SR scenarios
But those are very predominant in far feed
Recognition sot because of that reason after
I Was Introduced to the Far Feed
Recognition Problem by Mike During My
Internship Here I Started Working In
This area a lot and this was this one
Particular Table This was the state of ours
Carly's Army Recipe Last Summer Before the J
Salt Workshop During the Gelt Workshop
We Can Work for the TD and Bring It
Down to Some Extent and After the Workshop
We Started Doing Using Strong And
Strung Models and We Got Up To
46.1 Just Using the BSTA Models and
Even If You Use a Lot of Other Tricks Lie
Using Clean Alignments for Training and
Using Beam Form Audio Data All That You Can
Get Is You Could Just Move From 53 To 38.3 So
First of all when you do anything on pa
Feel Recognition The Guess Are So Significant
So It's Very Satisfying But The Other Good
The thing about this problem is that
Despina Able to Match the Performance of the
Close Talk Microphone System Which Was
Relative Degradation at This There's a 69
And this is not ground truth in terms
Of Human Performance Versus System
Performance These Are Two Systems Which Are
Exactly Train on the Same Data and Same
Language Models The Only Thing That Differs
Over here is acoustic data and what it gives
Relative Degradation on Giving a 69 It's a
Really
Good Motivation to Work on This Problem So
Most of My Focus Recently Has Been In
this particular
case so thank you
This is where I came from and where I came from.
Scrub a block what is applied an image
Processing Pyramid to Speech in Sense Ry
So ya ling da same th da de do fur translation
In and so basically what you're doing this time
direction
Y Kai Gut Who's Speed ​​Up Them Limited
You must run it on a mobile device and
ya so di suggestion wa me ba ra one i shd di wa
Sashi Wa Suggesting Actually Using The Sub
Salving Techniques Between the Fancy and the Tay
Had the il lim a guess that's what or accept
Ng alang itu is that's li v ge m bir gage
Don is 4
kapo 56
pixel b
i so
So So You Started With This Motivation A
I guess they will approach me
ATTACK F F F Y ONE E I STRAT ADDRESS
Models That Specifically Address Two Presses
f a d s sum your
motion
Apo Rel Bots Basically We Prove Er And
Aa g g don't 1 2s
The Timeline Wa Bit Arve So Our Il Gol Wa
Basically have an aesthetic model improve
Aesthetic models perform well every where and
It turns out that such aesthetic models are because
There are very specific conditions of tackling
Things are very much working for better in the
ff fee recognition case so y o ok
So I think that's the problem really is
Basically We So If You Do If You Guys Do
Achieve the Human Patty in Your Future
Basically Start Relaxing
Constraints in which you are recording
Speech And There And I Believe That There Is No
Separate robe smell problem and after feed
Recognition problem there is basically speech
Recognition Problem and I Guess Any Kind
Off acoustic model which is performing well
Would Actually Give Benefits in Lot of This
Cases S Soon As You Start Relaxing
These Constraints in Which We Are in Which We
Awesome That We're Going to Operate
in
So to sir more specifically so assume that
You Do Have a Certain Kind of Techniques
Let's see the techniques which work on a
Raw Speech So Which Are Showing Slight
Improvements in terms of performance
In the actual clean speech telephone speech
Recognition Case Those Same Techniques Wood
Actually Give Us Far More Improvements A
End Papers By the Last Inter Speech End
A I Have Shown That When We Apply Raw
signal processing raw signal technique
Models in Far Feel Recognition You Do Get
Better Guess Than You Normally
See So I Don't See A Really Strong
Distinction between these two problems but
Come or I definitely think that even if you
Start Just Focus on the Fee Recognition
Problems You'd See Guessing at the Normal
The problem is so simple that you just give it to me.
How they can approach the problem and try to make it
sn feature le sn feature le it the system has a
Mall the Summers Ticket Past in Operation
Aud the Model Keep Some Hin End
basicnet.nic has the same architecture so
Recently there was a set of features called
Scatter Features Propose So Computationally This
R a k convolution neural network and the
The only difference is where you are computing
Using Fix Filters So and Here
Filters Are Designed for You to Achieve All This
Distortion Stability Guarantees That I Was
Talking About So You'd Have All These Things
And on top of that you would use what
Any Acoustic Model You Wanted and the Other Way
Would be to basically make this a learnable model
And basically tune everything so there was
Recent Publications in December 2015
People Shad That In Order To Prove That Here
Model has a particular guarantee it is not
necessary
to
Restricting Filters So If You Have a
Design Filter You Have a Lot of Good
Understanding What the Filters Are
You know that it's a wavelet which has this
dilating
Gush As You Go To The Larger Bandwidth But They Show
That in order to make proofs about a
Stability and the Guarantee It Was Not
Necessary to have
This design is also possible with learn
Filters and all that you wanted over there
This very specific characteristic in
Terms of the Model Design Vi Wa Temporally
Local and frequency local transforms
These days case and the cushion operation
At So Late Been Late Becomes Strong To Turn
This transform from raw signals right
And over the past two or three years it's
Only in the last breath they are
Actually Showing the Learn Filters That Give
Had var performing slightly better than m fc6
But even if it's late, no guarantee is given.
Filters Were Going to Perform as Well If
There was a slight deviation in the training
Condition
Mismatch So I Think The Filter Is Feature Based
Approach Has One Fundamental Floss One Thing
That Absolutely Cannot Model The Model Based
approach the suggestion
युन व इन अर्व कि कि
Object One Specific Limit Filter
summon able to
Mal Peed Anoze Them Under The Future Bros
There is no under range of what is very good
For the particular task they solve
Problem using several different features
So in if your doing multi scale approach you
Would Just Not Use Single Filter Bank in Fear
To generate yo multi scale
Representation
Ok